le 8 septembre 2021 le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre s'ouvre à paris
dans une salle spécialement construite
pour l'événement
certaines personnes qui ont été blessées
ou qui ont perdu un proche ne souhaitent
pas nécessairement
s'exprimer pourquoi parce que la
souffrance est indicible elle est
inexprimable mais ce qu'elles attendent
c'est une justice particulièrement ferme
les actes qui sont reprochés aux accusés
sont des actes particulièrement
monstrueux durant six à huit mois plus
de 300 témoins vont se succéder face à
la cour et aux accusés parmi eux salah
abdeslam seul survivant des commandos du
groupe etat islamique
le premier jour du procès a été
consacrée à l'appel des accusés les
parties civiles et de leur avocat salahe
abdeslam s'est montré provocateur en
commençant par dire tout d'abord je
tiens à témoigner qu'il n'y a pas de
divinité à part à l'ats que mohammed est
son serviteur et son messager beyer
chercheurs sortir miettes clairement
au plein de raisons parce qu'il ya déjà
quand on veut rentrer ici hier matin
c'était l'effervescence incroyable donc
ça c'était vraiment un truc
dont on prend conscience uniquement
quand on le vicois clairement
ensuite il ya eu l'entrée du président
ça c'était vraiment un moment d'une
intensité
extrême williams eu l'impression que
tout vous submerge je voulais tout tour
revient à ce moment là quoi c'est
vraiment un moment a vraiment un
moyen idoine quoi sur
l'institution la société enfin tout est
là tout est réuni à ce moment là selon
moi à partir du 28 septembre les
témoignages des rescapés et des proches
des victimes commencent une séquence
longue de cinq semaines cité comme
témoin par l'association de victimes
life for parisse l'ancien président
françois hollande s'est exprimé le 10
novembre ce témoignage je le dois à
toutes les victimes à celles et ceux qui
ne sont plus là je sais la souffrance
que les victimes ont exprimé devant la
cour et je répondrai à toutes les
questions
[Musique]
je pense que françois hollande nous a
permis de mieux comprendre quel était le
degré de connaissance de l'état sur les
projets de l'état islamique à l'époque
sur ce qui avait pu être mis en oeuvre
il a aussi fait la lumière en partie sur
les opérations de police ce soir là en
disant qu'il avait donné son accord de
principe
dès son arrivée à la cellule place
beauvau et tous ces éléments là en fait
n'apparaissait pas encore dossier
n'était jamais apparu dans des
interviews dont on a appris des choses
et c'était ça le sens de le faire venir
aujourd'hui les accusés seront entendus
sur les faits dès janvier les premières
plaidoiries des parties civiles auront
lieu début avril pour un verdict attendu
à la fin du mois de mai